I wanted to ask another question about my heavy metals test that came back so high in the
gadolinium after my MRI in August.
I was kind of freaked out by that but then as I researched a little bit more, it seemed
like maybe that wasn't as horrifying as I thought because it would seem to mean that the gadolinium
hasn't completely settled into my brain and my tissues yet.
It's still circulating and I'm flushing it out through my urine.
So that's is that okay thinking or is that totally off missing the mark?
So clarify was the was the heavy metal test you did a urine test?
Yes.
Was it a provocation test?
What does that mean?
Meated, did you take a bunch of key later beforehand?
No.
Let's do a 24 hour urine.
Yes.
Okay, so in one sense, yeah, well I've get it out.
It's in my urine.
So there really isn't any great test for heavy metals.
So there's the hair analysis test.
Well, how accurate is that?
I don't know.
To be honest, I don't put a ton of faith in that.
There's the urinary 24 hour urine test.
Usually it's supposed to be a provocation test, meaning that you take
for a couple days, you take very strong kind of overdose on keylaters,
and then you do a 24 hour urine.
I don't like that test at all because
you're basically pulling a bunch of stuff out of the tissues,
and when I call phase zero detoxification process,
and you're dumping it into the blood, it basically overwhelms your liver,
and these are going to circulate around and dump somewhere else in the body.
What doesn't get out in the colon and in the urine?
I jump in here one second because I just remembered I did have to take a pill in warning
before I started.
There was 500 milligrams I think of something or other,
and I don't remember any more what it was.
There was probably either DMSA or EDTA.
Yes, yeah, it was.
Those, that sounds familiar.
Yeah, so I don't, that's why I don't like those tests,
because you could actually, you could make the person sick.
So I don't test for heavy metals with lab tests,
to be, if that's my only two choices, which it is,
I don't, I don't do that.
But yes, you are.
That tells you that you are, when you take a key later,
you're pulling it out of the tissue and you're dumping it.
That does still tell you that you have a lot of gadolinium in you.
Now that may indicate that the pathway in which you get rid of gadolinium,
you do have some hindrances there.
It would be interesting to do a study of 100 people
that did an MRI, and one month later, you do that same test
and see how many of them have elevated gadolinium.
I would be willing to bet that it would be a small amount,
because not everybody has issues with gadolinium.
They're able to readily get rid of it.
It's maybe on the AT pathways or the PUN1 pathways probably.
So there are some people that have such issues
and get rid of gadolinium that they end up getting really sick.
And there's websites, some people that have gadolinium toxicity disorders.
So most people don't have problems with it.
This would suggest that you have some.
Just, you know, that's why we try to use a holiocath,
because it's a mild key later.
What else can you do?
I would look at the mild keylators.
If you want to add anything else to your protocol again,
I would also mainly support your liver detox pathways.
So if you haven't read the seven phases of detox book,
that might be helpful to put the whole picture together
to make sure that you're pulling stuff out of the tissues
and then it's getting blocked in a dam somewhere downstream
and then just circulate around your body
and could actually make yourself more ill.
So you're having really good bowel movements.
If you feel like, you know, you don't have any gallbladder issues,
then looking at phase one and phase two pathways in the liver,
that's your site of Crumpet 450 and your PUN1 pathways.
I don't know your genes on top of my head,
but if you have any PUN,
what issues, which most cancer patients do,
maybe wrapping up the PUN1 products would be in a order.
Puma granite is a good food to support the PUN pathway as well.
Those are the kind of things I would look at.
I did notice that I saw I still have some chlorella
and spirulina powders laying around.
Is it good to throw those in my smoothie for now?
Yep, go.
And you close up and then maybe get after I'm done with those,
get another key later.
And maybe I would use mild keylators like that though.
And if I'm taking PUN1 already,
I'm taking 4 tablets a day.
What does that mean if I'm going to ramp that up?
Well, maybe for a time being, go up to six a day and remember the nice thing about the capsule
versus taking it in a smoothie is that you can take it more throughout the day,
because you have a half, you get all these supplements have a half-life in your body.
So if you can kind of keep that support because your liver is working 24-7,
and so if you can take split that through the day every three hours,
that would be best if you're good at doing that.
All right.
And by the way, I did come across the research where they have tested people who had a contrast
MRI for the first time and they found gadolinium in their system years later elevated.
Yeah, it can be because of the gadolinium is an element of a periodic table that's kind of
half-life of about 20 billion years or something.
Seems like it.
Okay, thank you.